SPEAKER 1: We created
a lock system.
And so this lock, it
works through sound.
So we have a
microphone here, and it
detects a specific rhythm.
See it have the right tempo
and right space between beats
for it to detect the--
for it to unlock.
So let me just plug this in.
So it starts in an unlock state.
We have a server right here.
This is for concept.
It's not the most sturdier
things, little cardboard
little flap.
So I'll put that
here to demonstrate.
So plug that here.
So let's say we
want to set a code.
So we're going to hold the
button for two seconds--
or that.
HARRY: So it detects it
three times in a row,
both to make sure you can
enter the code repeatedly,
and also to average
your results together.
So that if you were a little
quick or a little slow
on one of the taps,
that you don't
have to do that consistently,
that it knows what you
meant to do after a few tries.
SPEAKER 1: Luckily
we replace that code,
so instead of boring you
all, we'll just lock this,
but we'll lock the safe.
HARRY: Let's reset.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
HARRY: We were having hardware
issues with our button.
SPEAKER 1: This button
is not very cut.
SPEAKER 3: It was
working really well.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, geez.
HARRY: And beat to
set it to easy unlock.
His single clap is always--
SPEAKER 3: So now if
we press the button--
SPEAKER 1: Well,
this is embarrassing,
because this worked
two minutes ago.
SPEAKER 3: It worked
Can you come back to us?
SPEAKER 4: Some
too tight in there.
Now the lights.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Yeah, so the lights--
basically, we have a lot
of light and sound systems
that denote different things.
That's if it works.
Let's say we put a
code that's wrong.
So let's do that a couple
more times incorrectly.
So now on the third
fail, it'll kind of lock.
It's a simulated
calling the police.
Let's just try programming.
We'll try programming a code.
It's OK.
Hold on.
Let me just reset
this whole thing.
[INAUDIBLE] This'll work.
OK, let's try
programming a new code.
No.
Not that.
[INAUDIBLE] Unfortunately,
the sensor--
to determine what kind of sound
it's supposed to register--
there are a lot of difficulties.
And Harry can talk about those.
HARRY: The sensor has a
tremendous amount of drift,
about five times as
much drift is actually
the sensitivity to sound.
So before every
sound measure, we
have to take a
background reading.
It also only detects
low pitched claps.
If you hit your
fingers to your palm,
it won't detect that noise.
If you palm to palm, it
will detect that noise.
It also requires
fairly loud claps.
A gentle clap won't set it off.
You have to really make
a fair amount of noise.
Also, depending on how
your hands come together,
the sound comes out in
different directions,
causing it to detect
they're not detected.
So obviously, part of phase two,
if we were to expand on this,
is to get a better piece
of sound-sensing hardware
that is capable of detecting
a broader range of sounds,
with a little more sensitivity.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
That's our project.
HARRY: But it worked
for proof of concept.
SPEAKER 4: Number
one [INAUDIBLE]..